I'd like to start by asking
you to imagine a color
that you've never seen before.
Just for a second give this a try.
Can you actually visualize a color
that you've never been able to perceive?
I never seem to get tired of trying this
although I know
it's not an easy challenge.
And the thing is,
we can't imagine something
without drawing upon our experiences.
A color we haven't yet seen
outside the spectrum we can perceive
is outside our ability to conjure up.
It's almost like there's a boundary
to our imagination
where all the colors we can imagine
can only be various shades of other colors
we have previously seen.
Yet we know for a fact
that those color frequencies
outside our visible spectrum are there.
And scientists believe
that there are species
that have many more photo receptors
than just the three color ones
we humans have.
Which, by the way,
not all humans see the world
in the same way.
Some of us are colorblind
to various degrees,
and very often we don't even
agree on small things,
like if a dress on the internet
is blue and black or white and gold.
But my favorite creature,
one of my favorite creatures,
is the peacock mantis shrimp,
which is estimated to have 12
to 16 photo receptors.
And that indicates the world to them
might look so much more colorful.
So what about artificial intelligence?
Can AI help us see
beyond our human capabilities?
Well, I've been working with AI
for the past five years,
and in my experience, it can see
within the data it gets fed.
But then you might be wondering, OK,
if AI can't help imagine anything new,
why would an artist see
any point in using it?
And my answer to that is because I think
that it can help augment our creativity
as there's value in creating combinations
of known elements to form new ones.
And this boundary of what we can imagine
based on what we have experienced
is the place that I have been exploring.
For me, it started with jellyfish
on a screen at an aquarium
and wearing those old 3D glasses,
which I hope you remember,
the ones with the blue and red lens.
And this experience made me want
to recreate their textures.
But not just that,
I also wanted to create new jellyfish
that I hadn't seen before, like these.
And what started with jellyfish,
very quickly escalated
to other sea creatures
like sea anemone, coral and fish.
And then from there came amphibians,
birds and insects.
And this became a series
called “Neural Zoo”.
But when you look closely,
what do you see?
There's no single creature
in these images.
And AI augments my creative process
by allowing me to distill
and recombine textures.
And that's something that would otherwise
take me months to draw by hand.
Plus I'm actually terrible at drawing.
So you could say, in a way, what I'm doing
is a contemporary version of something
that humans have already
been doing for a long time,
even before cameras existed.
In medieval times,
people went on expeditions,
and when they came back
they would share about what they saw
to an illustrator.
And the illustrator, having never seen
what was being described,
would end up drawing
based on the creatures
that they had previously seen
and in the process creating
hybrid animals of some sort.
So an explorer might describe a beaver,
but having never seen one,
the illustrator might give it
the head of a rodent,
the body of a dog and a fish-like tail.
In the series
“Artificial Natural History”,
I took thousands of illustrations
from a natural history archives,
and I fed them to a neural network
to generate new versions of them.
But up until now,
all my work was done in 2D.
And with the help of my studio partner,
Feileacan McCormick,
we decided to train a neural network
on a data set of 3D scanned beetles.
But I must warn you that our first
results were extremely blurry,
and they looked
like the blobs you see here.
And this could be due to many reasons,
but one of them being
that there aren't really a lot
of openly available
data sets of 3D insects.
And also we were repurposing
a neural network that normally gets used
to generate images to generate 3D.
So believe it or not,
these are very exciting blobs to us.
But with time and some
very hacky solutions
like data augmentation,
where we threw in ants
and other beetle-like insects
to enhance the data set,
we ended up getting this,
which we've been told
they look like grilled chicken.
(Laughter)
But hungry for more,
we pushed our technique,
and eventually they ended up
looking like this.
We use something called 3D style transfer
to map textures onto them,
and we also trained
a natural language model
to generate scientific-like names
and anatomical descriptions.
And eventually we even found a network
architecture that could handle 3D meshes.
So they ended up looking like this.
And for us, this became a way
of creating kind of a speculative study --
(Applause)
A speculative study of creatures
that never existed,
kind of like a speculative biology.
But I didn't want to talk
about AI and its potential
unless it brought me closer
to a real species.
Which of these do you think is easier
to find data about online?
(Laughter)
Yeah, well, as you guessed
correctly, the red panda.
And this maybe could be
due to many reasons,
but one of them being how cute they are,
which means we photograph
and talk about them a lot,
unlike the boreal felt lichen.
But both of them
are classified as endangered.
So I wanted to bring visibility
to other endangered species
that don't get the same amount
of digital representation
as a cute, fluffy red panda.
And to do this,
we trained an AI on millions of images
of the natural world,
and then we prompted with text
to generate some of these creatures.
So when prompted with a text,
"an image of a critically endangered
spider, the peacock tarantula"
and its scientific name,
our model generated this.
And here's an image
of the real peacock tarantula,
which is a wonderful spider
endemic to India.
But when prompted with a text
"an image of a critically
endangered bird, the mangrove finch,"
our model generated this.
And here's a photo
of the real mangrove finch.
Both these creatures exist in the wild,
but the accuracy of each generated image
is fully dependent on the data available.
These chimeras of our everyday data
to me are a different way
of how the future could be.
Not in a literal sense, perhaps,
but in the sense that through practicing
the expanding of our own imagination
about the ecosystems we are a part of,
we might just be better equipped
to recognize new opportunities
and potential.
Knowing that there's a boundary
to our imagination
doesn't have to feel limiting.
On the contrary,
it can help motivate us
to expand that boundary further
and to seek out colors
and things we haven't yet seen
and perhaps enrich
our imagination as a result.
So thank you.
(Applause)